it's the perfect bio weapon caused by
bacillus anthracis a bacteria commonly
found in soil across the world
anthrax is the disease nightmares are
made of
its spores can survive hostile
environments for centuries at a time
able to infect anyone who touches
ingests or
breathes in even a tiny amount its
fatality rate can be over 90 percent
yet it's not so much the deadlines of
anthrax that makes it so potent
but the ease of distribution once
refined it can be mailed to victims used
to
infect their food or water or even
sprayed from a plane flying overhead
according to experts just 100 kilograms
of aerosolized anthrax would be enough
to kill three
million people and render entire cities
uninhabitable for generations
thankfully such attacks are exceedingly
rare to date only one bioterrorist has
succeeded in causing mass casualties
with anthrax when
spore filled letters killed five
americans in 2001. but that doesn't mean
there haven't been
many close calls across the decades
everyone from the nazis to the british
to japanese doomsday cults have
experimented with anthrax weapons
in some cases coming close to making
them a terrifying reality
[Music]
of all the microscopic killers in nature
smallpox ebola the plague
perhaps none is quite so flat out creepy
as bacillus
anthracis a rod-shaped bacteria that
comes in three strains
anthracis exists naturally in soil from
the americas to africa to eurasia in
some ways it's pretty benign
only rarely affecting humans it's
non-contagious meaning it can't be
passed between people in
the way that say coronaviruses can but
that's just the silver lining to the
deadly cloud that is
bacillusanthrasis because while it may
not be able to sweep across the planet
it has other talents that are far
scarier
the worst of these may be its ability to
produce spores
once created these spores can lie
dormant in soil or animal fur
for decades or maybe even centuries in
britain for example viable spores were
recently discovered in an excavated
hospital dating from the middle ages
yet it's only while in the wild that
these spores lie dormant once they get
inside a body by touch or inhalation
all bets are off in no time at all new
bacteria are multiplying inside the host
spreading toxins with a
terrifying speed the disease these
toxins cause is known as anthrax and
it's among the deadliest illnesses known
to man interestingly there are three
different ways of contracting anthrax
none of them
are exactly a barrel of laughs but some
are certainly worse than others the most
common
is thankfully also the mildest cutaneous
anthrax is when those spores get inside
you via a cut or an insect bite
causing dark black lesions on your skin
hence the name
anthrax from the greek for coal while
pretty gross this is also easily
treatable even if you ignore all medical
advice and just let it do its thing it
still only has a 20 chance of killing
you the next most dangerous form is the
rarest
gastrointestinal anthrax is caused by
eating infected meat and can kill
up to 60 percent of its victims but
since most farmers are clever enough not
to package and sell meat of an animal
that's just died of some super
mysterious illness
almost no one today gets this type of
the disease this just leaves us with the
third
and final form inhalation anthrax it's
at this point that nature
turns up the terror to eleven anywhere
between a week and two months after
exposure you'll start to experience a
low fever
combined with chills normally this fever
will abate after only a few days but
this is just a false recovery shortly
after your temperature will shoot up
extreme pain will grip your chest
followed by vomiting fits that expel
blood
your body will go into toxic shock start
shutting down the entire process from
onset to death can take just 48 hours
untreated and in most cases hospitals
won't know you even have it prior to
autopsy
less than 15 percent of patients survive
inhalation anthrax the bad news
this is exactly the type most likely to
be used as a bioweapon still we should
stress that anthrax infections are
currently rare in most of the world
the us has so few cases that it averages
less than one per year
prior to 2000 no american had been
diagnosed with inhalation anthrax since
1976.
globally there may be as few as 20 000
cases a year not bad coming from a
population of nearly 8 billion but that
doesn't mean humanity's history with
anthrax has always been so placid
over the centuries bacillus and thrasus
has caused death and destruction
on an unimaginable scale
today the exact origins of anthrax are a
mystery as
is the moment it first showed up in the
historical record there are ancient
chinese texts that some think contain
the first known description of the
disease but
others point the finger at the old
testament the fifth plague in egypt in
the book of exodus is a mysterious
disease that quickly kills off livestock
this is followed by the sixth plague
which causes boils to break out on the
skin of humans
for some modern readers this sounds a
whole lot like ancient egyptians getting
cutaneous anthrax after handling their
dead and diseased animals
just as we still don't know when anthrax
appeared wear
likewise remains a mystery there's also
a lot of genetic diversity among the
bacteria
in both southern africa and eurasia
suggesting the bacteria originated on
one of these places but
somewhere in either africa europe or
asia doesn't exactly narrow things
down we're also not totally sure how it
got from its birthplace to
the soil of every single continent but a
good guess is that humans were involved
not so long ago stumbling across an
animal that had died of some unknown
illness was less of a reason to freak
out and
more of a reason to be like way free
stuff clothing made from animals killed
by anthrax would still have contained
spores
spores our forebears then spread around
as they traveled one piece of evidence
we have for this is that anthrax was
one of the few non-native diseases
already in the americas when europeans
arrived
genetic testing has shown that the
bacteria likely arrived via alaska
fifteen thousand years ago before
spreading south
exactly what you'd expect to see if it
traveled alongside the first humans
another clue comes in the form of
genetic data that shows one of the
bacteria's three varieties going crazy
around 3000 bc 3000 bc just happens to
line up with the dawn of the bronze age
a period where eurasians were
just starting to get super into the idea
of long distance trade with livestock
farming already bringing people into
contact with
anthrax carrying animals it seems
plausible these same people then spread
the spores
along ancient trade routes and so began
several long millennia of b
anthracis super killing any humans
unlucky enough to get infected with it
in the ancient world the roman poet
virgil described a plague that spread
from animals to humans one that caused
high fevers
and lesions breaking out on the skin of
anyone who touched the animal's fur
come the middle ages anthrax was so
endemic in europe that it was nicknamed
the black bane there's even a theory
that the mysterious sweating sickness
that afflicted england across the late
15th and early 16th centuries
may have been anthrax certainly the
symptoms fit vomiting high fever extreme
aches death within 48 hours
so deadly was the sweating sickness that
it terrified chroniclers even those
who'd
grown up hearing tales of the then
recent black death
but that's anthrax for you it's freaky
and it's
deadly as heck in 1770 for example a
suspected outbreak in san doming now
haiti
is said to have killed 15 000 in just
six weeks but this would also turn out
to be one of the last
great gasps of the disease come the 19th
century humankind was finally beginning
to fight back
[Music]
the first anthrax breakthrough came in
1850 the year french physician
casimir devane identified the rod-shaped
bacteria
known as bacillus enthrasis however you
could argue that humanity's path to
understanding the disease actually began
seven years earlier
on december the 11th 1843. that's when
robert koch was born
in northwest germany the third of an
incredible 13 kids [ __ ] would grow up to
be a key figure in early micro biology
and it's his work on anthrax that would
really make his name in the early 1870s
[ __ ] finished his stint as an army
doctor in the franco-prussian war
and moved to wallstein today wallstein
in poland it was a fortunate move for
science because [ __ ] arrived
as wallstein was in the grip of a deadly
plague in just four years this small
town had recorded 56 000
animal and 528 human deaths from anthrax
the situation was so bad that entire
pastures were considered off-limits
their
soil certain to kill anything grazing
there naturally this was exactly the
sort of medical problem [ __ ] was
obsessed with
he began performing experiments testing
the blood of dead animals and the soils
that had infected them it was [ __ ] who
definitively linked anthrax to bacillus
enthrasis who discovered its spores
and their near indestructible nature it
was the first time in history a specific
disease was proven to be caused by one
type of bacteria and it allowed [ __ ] to
make further recommendations such as
burning the corpses of infected animals
nor were his discoveries limited to
germany over in northern britain
there had been an ever-growing panic
about wool sorter's disease
first reported in 1838 it affected only
those who worked with wool causing black
lesions on hands
lesions that sometimes graduated to a
deadly pneumonia when two local doctors
called edison and bell red of cock's
discoveries they realized that wool
sorter's disease had to be anthrax
although proving it was a gruesome
process involving injecting blood from a
man killed by the sickness into healthy
animals
their work transformed british
industrial health laws but by then
another scientist already built on
cock's work
to take the human battle with anthrax to
the next level by the early 1880s louis
pasteur
was already famous the inventor of
pasteurization his work was saving tens
of thousands of lives every year
in his native france alone but pastor
was also living through an anthrax
epidemic
scores of humans and uncountable animals
were dying from the disease
when he heard of cock's breakthrough
there was only one thing on pasteur's
mind
to show that german doofus what real
genius looked like
in the spring of 1881 having gathered
funding from
farmers desperate to end the plague
pasteur conducted a public experiment
of his new anthrax vaccine at pulitzer 4
crowds gathered to watch him inoculate
24 sheep six cows and one
goat while an identically sized control
group was left
unvaccinated nearby on may 31 pasteur
injected all the animals with anthrax
bacteria and told the crowd to return
two days later when they did they found
the entire control group dead
or dying meanwhile not a single
vaccinated animal had succumbed it was a
massive breakthrough
one that transformed agriculture
although not safe for use in humans
pasteur's vaccine
hugely decreased anthrax outbreaks among
livestock coupled with max stern's even
safer vaccine of the 1930s it soon
looked like anthrax might be consigned
to the dustbin of history but even as
the fight against anthrax and animals
was gaining pace
the world's military scientists were
coming to a worrying realization what if
there was more to anthrax than simply
being a scourge
what if they could take this bacteria
refine it
and turn it into a weapon
[Music]
considering it was a war in which
supposedly civilized countries chugged
mustard gas at one another
it's a miracle anthrax didn't feature in
world war one by now
the world knew what caused the disease
knew about the hardy spores that could
infect people even years later
yet the only recorded use of anthrax in
world war one came from german saboteurs
infecting horses sold to the allies from
mutual countries
despite this having no effect on the war
beyond upsetting animal lovers
bioweapons were still banned by the 1925
geneva protocol
remarkably this is a convention most of
the signatories would stick to in the
coming decades
but not all of them over in the far east
a new power was rising that would turn
anthrax into a deadly weapon it was
during 1932 that imperial japan first
started experimenting
on human subjects in occupied manchuria
prisoners were exposed anthrax among
many other nasty diseases and monitored
to see how long they lasted
the upshot was that by 1937 tokyo had
built up a fearsome arsenal of
biological weapons
weapons it was all too ready to use on
china's civilian population
from the outbreak of the second
sino-japanese war anthrax played
a small but grotesque part under the
first watch of commander shiroishi
japan's unit 731 infected civilian
prisoners with the bacteria
before vivisecting them without
anesthetic anthrax was also among the
diseases including the plague that
imperial japan sprayed directly over
chinese towns
all told it's thought ishi's bio-terror
campaign killed around 300 000 civilians
because reality laughs at the idea of
karma
she ended the war not being strung up a
mussolini style but being granted
immunity
by the usa congratulations washington
but while japan's anthrax program was
unique in its scale and cruelty
it wasn't the only one to exist during
world war ii over 9 000 kilometers away
the british were also trying to figure
out how to turn the disease against
their enemies
london's bioweapons program had begun
back in 1936 when spies reported that
germany was investing
in germ warfare when world war ii
exploded army research lab portend down
began running tests on everything
from foot and mouth to rinderpest the
plan was to develop a weapon that would
mass kill nazi germany's livestock
hopefully causing panic and starvation
care to guess what disease turned out to
be perfect for this in the summer of
1942 the government took control of the
uninhabited scottish island
of grunard sheep were tethered in open
pens and then anthrax spores were
dropped from a low-flying plane to call
the test a success would be
to underestimate just what a slaughter
it was the anthrax spores killed all the
sheep
within three days unfortunately they
also rendered the island completely
uninhabitable even when the war ended
the island remained off limits its soil
so contaminated that
even creatures living in the chernobyl
exclusion zone would be like
not gonna visit there it took until the
mid-1980s before grenade could be
decontaminated and only after the uk
government
removed the topsoil and doused whatever
was left with formaldehyde
thanks to incidents like this it pretty
soon became clear that stockpiling
literal tons of anthrax was
a pretty terrible idea by the mid-20th
century it was estimated that a mere 100
kilograms would be enough to wipe out
three million people
and render entire cities uninhabitable
for generations
clearly humankind couldn't go on like
this not
if it wanted to survive into the next
century it was time
to finally ban once and for all the use
of bio weapons
the only problem was that not everyone
was willing to go along
cataclysmic disasters can spring from
the tiniest things
just look at challenger destroyed by a
simple seal not working in the cold or
chernobyl triggered by an unnecessary
safety test for the people of sverdlovsk
now known as yet katerinburg
the cause of all their misery would
eventually be traced to a single broken
air filter it was now april of 1979.
exactly seven years ago the ussr
had joined the u.s and a hundred other
countries in signing the biological
weapons convention
intended to hold weapons research into
and the stockpiling of everything from
anthrax to smallpox
the convention supposedly ended the
bioweapons era sadly for sverdlovsk
the soviet signatory had apparently kept
their fingers crossed that spring 1979
the city was struck
by an anthrax outbreak although precise
numbers are impossible to come by
it's known that anywhere between 68 and
105 people died of the disease
at the time the soviet authorities
declared all those killed off had eaten
infected meat
bought on the black market it wasn't
until 1992 after the collapse of
communism that
outside researchers were allowed in to
investigate by plotting each of the
victims on a map they soon discovered
that the disease had moved across the
city
in almost a straight line a line that
led right back to the broken air filter
at a nearby bioweapons lab the svedlovsk
leak was a grim reminder of just how
deadly anthrax can be but it was also
a piece of tremendous luck had the wind
been blowing in the opposite direction
the spores would have been carried right
into the city's downtown
and hundreds of thousands could have
died but the soviets weren't the only
ones still playing with biological fire
south africa's truth and reconciliation
committee would report in the 1990s that
the apartheid regime had stockpiled
anthrax using the spores for
at least one assassination it's also
been suspected that rhodesia's white
minority government likewise deployed
the
disease during the bush war although any
records have been destroyed
but despite these incidents by and large
the 70s and 80s saw a steady reduction
of nations growing anthrax for their
militaries
instead nature's perfect bioweapon came
to the attention
of even scarier entities terrorists
the first non-state group to play around
with anthrax was likely
dark harvest a still mysterious group
they managed to remove two barrels of
spore laden soil
from scotland's grenade island the first
barrel was left outside port and down
the second was
dumped outside that year's conservative
party conference although
at least one of the barrels was found to
be contaminated with spores nobody was
sickened in either attack
indeed it might not even be fair to call
them attacks the speculation that dark
harvest were really just a bunch of
scottish locals fed up with living so
close to a dangerous island
after the uk government decontaminated
grenade the group were never heard from
again
so yes it's fair to say terrorism's
flirtation with anthrax did not get off
to an auspicious start
sadly this state of affairs wouldn't
last over the following decade two very
different very scary people were
going to try and go beyond anything dark
harvest had attempted
unfortunately one of them was going to
succeed
[Music]
march 20th 1995 was a fine day in tokyo
one of those bright spring mornings that
makes you feel
glad you're alive deep below the city
though in the darkness of the subway
system a very different story was
unfolding at the height of rush hour
members of the om shinrikyo doomsday
cult had simultaneously punctured bags
of sarin
on multiple trains the resulting cloud
of nerve gas killed 13 people and
sickened 6 000
it remains the worst terrorist attack in
japanese history but it was only when
the police raided orms headquarters that
they discovered sarin had been the
cult's backup option
the original plan had been to paralyze
tokyo with an anthrax attack one of the
wealthiest cults of all time om had
recruited from japan's elite targeting
those with
knowledge of wmds two of their members
had worked in microbiology and were able
to acquire a small number of anthrax
spores
spoils that the cult had cultured in
gigantic evil smelling bats
in 1993 an aerosolized version had been
sprayed across tokyo in the hopes that
it would kill thousands luckily even the
colt's microbiologists weren't anthrax
experts the strain they used was
incapable of harming humans
it was because of this failure that alm
turned to creating its own nerve gas
but while om's anthrax plans would be a
hideous failure
the same can't be said for their
american counterpart the first sign
america got that was under attack by
bioweapons
came on october the 2nd 2001. it was
just three weeks since 9 11. three weeks
in which the nation had barely had time
to mourn
let alone prepare for another terrorist
atrocity so when photo editor robert
stevens checked into a florida hospital
suffering inhalation anthrax
everyone assumed it was just a freak
accident even when spores were found at
his workplace
no one dared imagine they could have
been placed there deliberately
then on october 12th a letter containing
powdered anthrax was opened at nbc
poisoning an employee two days after
that another letter contaminated
congress
one of the fbi's biggest fears had been
realized terrorists were now in
possession
of weaponized anthrax the 2001 anthrax
attack lasted until november
21st when the last victim a 94 year old
woman
died in connecticut overall 22 people
were infected
five of whom died today a lot of
question marks still hang over the case
codenamed
amerithrax officially the fbi and doj
consider it closed
in 2008 they were on the cusp of
arresting anthrax expert dr bruce ivins
when
he committed suicide along alona with
rage issues and violent fantasies
ivan certainly fit the profile of a lone
wolf terrorist
however he was never charged and
subsequent inquiries found flaws in the
investigation
still whether it was the work of dr
ivans or not the attacks changed the way
washington viewed anthrax
in the aftermath u.s cleanup crews were
dispatched to anthrax hot spots
including the abandoned soviet
bioweapons lab of
irasc 7. there millions of dollars were
spent
destroying spores in the ground lest
groups inspired by the 2001 attacks try
and
acquire their own anthrax but it seems
no one ever did
since 2001 there have been no recorded
cases of anthrax used as a bioweapon
while hoax letters are still a
continuing problem in 2019 alone they
were
mailed in both the usa and the uk actual
successful anthrax attacks remain
non-existent but that doesn't mean
anthrax doesn't still pose a major
danger
in 2016 an unusually warm summer in
siberia saw a layer of permafrost melt
for the first time
in 80 years as it melted it reactivated
dormant spores in the frozen carcass of
a reindeer that had died nearly a
century earlier
from this one corpse an anthrax outbreak
swept the region killing
untold numbers of reindeer and infecting
72 humans
and tragically one 12-year-old boy died
if one corpse can cause such damage
imagine
what hundreds or even thousands could do
now think about
all those millions of animals that have
died of anthrax in polar climates over
the centuries
animals that were buried in the
permafrost and may still
carry deadly spores as climate change
warms our world it's likely that we'll
see
more cases like this in russia in canada
in alaska
in scandinavia more cases of long-buried
anthrax suddenly
reactivated ready to spread and infect
new victims
the story of humanity's struggle with
anthrax then is far from over
while we have the upper hand there's no
telling what the future holds
because make no mistake this bacteria is
one of the most perfect killing machines
to have ever evolved a disease capable
of making entire cities
uninhabitable we may be winning the war
against our microscopic enemies
but there's still a long way left to go
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe
and as always thank you for watching